esta situación de fuego cruzado es la
última de una serie de hechos que está
elevando las tensiones en la frontera de
facto entre Israel y Líbano que
técnicamente están en guerra desde el
año 2006 y todo esto se produce en un
contexto de la operación a gran escala
israelí en jerin todo inició en horas de
la mañana desde el sur libanés se
lanzaron dos proyectiles uno cayó en
territorio libanés y el otro cerca de la
aldea de gallar en la zona fronteriza en
disputa y a estos respondieron las
fuerzas israelíes con al menos 15
disparos de artillería en áreas abiertas
de las colinas de kafasuba desde donde
provinieron los cohetes de momento las
autoridades de Israel no han dado
instrucciones especiales a quienes viven
en el área como ocurre cuando se dan
enfrentamientos de mayor envergadura
ahora bien antes de este intercambio el
grupo chivitages volá que controla el
sur del Líbano condenó lo que denominó
medidas peligrosas de Israel que ha
levantado una valla y un muro para en
palabras de gesbola tener plena
autoridad sobre la aldea de gallar esta
población de menos de 3.000 habitantes
de la comunidad alawita está atravesada
por la llamada línea Azul la frontera de
marcada por la ONU para separar al
Líbano e Israel la parte Norte reclamada
por Líbano y la parte Sur se ubica en
los altos del golán sirios que fueron
ocupados y anexados por Israel este a
priori Avanza en el control de la aldea
es visto como una presión de Israel
sobre hezbola después de que la
formación chinita instalara los últimos
dos meses dos tiendas de campaña dentro
del territorio que Israel reclama como
propio lo que ha llevado a semanas de
gestiones de la fuerza de paz de la ONU
para lograr el retiro de esas carpas
Aunque todavía no ha tenido éxito